I just heard that some people might not
think that the Last of Us cordycep
infected monsters are zombies because
they don't experience physiological
death but there's a couple things I
think I need to point out here if a
person loses their Humanity develops a
taste for human flesh in any capacity
can't control their instincts to kill
and is made a monster by a pandemic
level virus we're talking about a modern
zombie doll zombies today come in a lot
of shapes and sizes and have
dramatically changed from their original
Haitian vodu Origins so we need to
reconceptualize the definition and
there's actually a long history of
avoiding the Z word